on leur a dit d'ailleurs on l'a mis sur
une résistance c'est normal vous vous
luttez contre l'occupant sauf que prend
en otage des journalistes c'est pas
c'est pas de la résistance sont donc là
on comprend pas
alors Christian vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste du Moyen-Orient Radio France
et vous Georges journaliste spécialiste
du Moyen-Orient au Figaro voilà alors
vous publiez tous les deux chez Kalman
Levy un livre qui s'appelle mémoire
d'otage et sur la bande rouge notre
contre enquête alors en introduction
vous remercier les Français de leur
mobilisation pendant vos quatre mois de
détention en Irak et aussi les musulmans
de France
vous dites un immense choukrane voilà ça
nous a évidemment touché et puis ça nous
a beaucoup aidé je crois parce que nos
ravisseurs ont été sensible à
la marque de de
compréhension de la part des musulmans
de France qui sont venus à Bagdad et qui
ont entamé un dialogue avec avec des
gens qui étaient plus ou moins proches
de nos ravisseur d'ailleurs ils ont pas
bien compris ça les a surpris que des
musulmans prennent parti pour des
chrétiens et donc ça ils nous ont
demandé
expliquez-nous parce que eux pensent que
les musulmans de France sont opprimés
ont pas de liberté donc pour eux c'était
un peu bizarre de voir ces musulmans de
France venir à Bagdad et porter le
message de paix fraternité c'était un
beau geste c'était un très beau vraiment
un très beau
alors quand vous avez été libéré vous
avez découvert avec stupeur la
mobilisation en votre faveur le pape
le pape
non c'est vrai
tout à fait oui sur le pas paraphrafat
des mouvements islamistralico comme le
Hezbollah qui ont enlevé des français au
Liban il y a 20 ans donc ça lorsque j'ai
découvert ça je me suis dit il s'est
passé quelque chose et effectivement
cette mobilisation aussi a joué en notre
faveur parce que elle a elle a montré à
nos ravisseurs que si jamais il nous
tuait ils risquait d'avoir quelques
quelques problèmes au sein de leur de
leur communauté musulmane de comme on
dit ouais comment on dit vous racontez
votre libération vous affirmez qu'il n'y
a pas eu de rançon verset est-ce que
c'est parce que vous avez pas vu la
mallette pleine de billets ou vous savez
qu'il y en a pas eu
c'est sans doute les deux les gars il y
en a une
on n'a pas on n'a pas on n'a pas vu
de mallette
occasion c'est ça peut se faire et ça
n'est d'ailleurs pas donc inhabituel et
ça n'est pas moralement
répréhensiblement nous on ne l'a pas vu
et puis je crois qu'ils si jamais il y
avait une rançon et qu'on l'avait vu on
ne le dirait pas parce que c'est le
genre de choses qui peut nuire qui peut
nuire aux intérêts de la France qui peut
nuire à Florence aujourd'hui qui est
détenu donc se dire ça c'est se dire
c'est un presque un épiphénomène c'est 2
millions de dollars quand même un otage
oui alors c'est une estimation qu'on a
qu'on a eu de la part d'une personne qui
a servi d'intermédiaire mais c'est vrai
il y a un marché otage et c'est vrai
qu'il y a les Occidentaux des Italiens
des Français là des Australiens mais il
y a aussi beaucoup d'Irakiens qui sont
enlevés pour des kidnapping crapuleux
donc c'est un business donc c'est pour
ça que pour les journalistes maintenant
venir à Bagdad on augmente aussi de
marcher aux otages alors on sait pas si
une rançon on pense que oui dans tous
les cas vous vous avez rien vu en tous
les cas on sait qu'il y a eu un prix
politique à payer par la France ils ont
voulu avoir la certitude qui aurait pas
non plus de Français en Irak militaire
demain ou après-demain le discours de
Michel Barnier aux Nations Unies qui
étaient claire et puis il y a eu aussi
la petite phrase de Michel Barnier au
sommet de Charmel chair en novembre
lorsqu'il dit il faut les groupes armés
peuvent s'intégrer au processus
politique dès lors qui renonce aux armes
donc c'était quand même une petite
phrase assez difficile à prononcer avec
des des Américains en face de vous donc
on peut penser que ça pouvait être cette
ça qui recouvre donc le coup politique
alors vous dites on est enlevé par des
combattants dont nous comprenions le
sens de la lutte qui nous transforme en
colis et qui nous jette dans un coffre
c'est-à-dire que au départ vous êtes non
seulement français mais parmi les
Français vous êtes particulièrement je
dirais sensible au problème du monde
arabe
c'est à dire que avec George on a
coutume de dire on a 20 ans de
Moyen-Orient derrière nous donc on
connaît bien la région
donc c'est vrai qu'en Irak il y a une
occupation il y a eu une guerre qui
était illégale au regard du droit
international donc c'est vrai que on
leur a dit d'ailleurs une résistance
c'est normal vous luttez contre
l'occupant sauf que prend en otage des
joints Alice c'est pas c'est pas de la
résistance sont donc là on comprend pas
mais c'est encore pire je dirais de se
faire prendre un otage par des gens je
dis pas pour qui vous avez de la
sympathie mais enfin dont vous partagez
quand même globalement les idées je
crois c'est ce qu'ils ont compris aussi
ils ont compris parce que après ils nous
ont dit il y a deux catégories de tâches
pour nous ceux dont on négocie la
libération et ceux qu'on exécute et il
nous dit vous vous êtes dans la bonne
catégorie et bon donc je crois qu'on a
oui
tu as raison on leur disait américain
vous seriez pas là quoi c'est clair
américain ou anglais voilà alors vous
racontez votre captivité les jours sans
fin vous jouez à des jeux vous avez des
jeux c'est que sont-ils devenus du
football
voilà parce qu'on est qu'est-ce qu'il
est devenu Marcel Le Bourges
moi je suis prête Saint-Étienne alors 76
bon j'ai été assez passionné de foot au
foot
l'arché si on sait ce qu'il est devenu
mais il a mal tourné mais voilà donc on
essaie de souvenirs de personnages
politiques voilà vous jouez aussi au jeu
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé cette année là
voilà en 73 chez laringo oui
vous étiez flippé ou vous étiez résigné
ça dépend des moments ça dépend
globalement vous chialez
bah oui notamment on parle de cette
fameuse semaine du 8 novembre là on fait
vraiment là pour le coup la cassette de
menaces
le type vient nous voir et il est masqué
toujours avec des kalachnikov et
maintenant la situation est très
difficile pour vous elle est critique
votre président est endetté va rien
savoir ça n'avance sur rien
sachez que on peut vous liquider à tout
moment donc là et donc il me dit et
cette convaincre ton gouvernement de
faire quelque chose ah là ça commence
donc là bon et puis après il y a des
bombardements autour de la maison enfin
il y a des combats on est transféré sur
notre maison au moment de descendre dans
la voiture parce que nous mettons dans
cette pièce de cercueils ont été
bâillonnés ils nous disent les Français
croient pas la menace donc là on
s'effondre parce que s'il ne crois pas
la menace alors là et puis quand on
arrive dans la nouvelle maison il ouvre
la porte et il dit oui dead with alive
qui est mort qui est vivant et c'est là
qu'on se dit tout ça ils vont liquider à
nous oui c'est ça
encore vous étiez mutuellement pour
faire pression sur les Français qui
selon eux ne voulaient pas ne prenez pas
au sérieux
quoi donc on avait vu trois jours
d'angoisse chaque bruit métallique on
entendait derrière la porte on se disait
moi ils sont en train de préparer il y a
des moments effectivement incroyables
c'est quand ils vous propose de vous
convertir à l'islam alors évidemment
c'est difficile de refuser dans ces
cas-là alors pour eux pour ceux qui
arriveraient à vous convertir sur leur
ouvrirait les portes du Paradis bien
évidemment puisqu'ils auraient converti
quelqu'un chrétien et pour vous la
conversion à l'islam c'est le risque
d'être désigné comme comme kamikaze
comme bombe humaine appartement vous
êtes musulman
la première réaction qu'on a eu on s'est
dit bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait s'il
revienne alors on s'est dit il faut
qu'on imagine un scénario on va leur
dire on est on n'a pas de problème avec
l'islam on vit dans un pays arabe mais
simplement pour que la conversion soit
authentique moi je suis fiancé donc il
faut que j'en parle à mon ami
laissez-moi revenir à Paris et puis
je vais lui demander je reviens moi je
lui dis moi j'aimerais bien lire le
Coran en français parce que pour
connaître la parole
j'aimerais bien voir
mais il faut frapper comme un comme à
Madrid ils nous disent nous on veut
frapper l'Égypte on veut frapper
l'Arabie Saoudite quand je dis alors la
France non vous êtes vous êtes pas dans
le top de la liste mais voilà quoi donc
c'est des gens qui ont une vision du
monde un programme et qui sont prêts à
l'appliquer on voit bien tous les jours
enfin en Irak les kamikaze maintenant
c'est c'est tous les jours donc alors
voilà il y a une deuxième partie dans
votre livre qui est intéressante aussi
c'est la contre enquête c'est-à-dire que
là depuis que vous êtes revenu vous avez
travaillé donc évidemment vos ravisseurs
l'Armée islamique en Irak c'est des
c'est des ex de Saddam plus des
islamistes
plus Ben Laden donc c'est une fusion des
trois des trois composantes la direction
est peut-être islamiste pure et dur mais
je dirais entre guillemets la compétence
technique ce qui interroge ceux qui font
des attaques mais sont vraisemblablement
des anciens militaires des anciens
espions de Salam qui ont cette
compétence technique alors vous parlez
aussi de l'affaire Julien sur laquelle
vous avez enquêté parce que c'est une
histoire absolument incroyable cette
espèce de d'épopée d'équiper comme ça
sauvage alors Raffarin au départ il
croyait lui il dit et si Julien a réussi
c'est après tout jusqu'au 15 septembre
ça patauge en reprenant l'expression
d'un officier il y a aucun septembre le
président de la République on voit le
général Rondeau pour essayer de voir un
petit peu pourquoi rien ne vient du côté
notamment les services de renseignement
et donc pendant ces 3 semaines qui se
sont écoulées mais effectivement
Raffarin dit un jour et si et si Julien
réussissait donc j'ai bien parce que
dans le cadre d'une prise d'otage je
veux dire les interventions extérieures
comme ça peuvent être les bienvenus
simplement ce qu'il faut faire c'est
discret et pas aller avec trois voitures
de journalistes pour rentrer en Syrie et
puis dire je vais libérer les otages etc
donc c'est là où il y a eu il y a eu un
manquement de la part de de Didier Julia
et de ses hommes c'est qu'ils ont été
très très maladroits et vous l'avez
engueulé vous l'avez non rien du tout
absolument on l'a écouté juste la
descente de l'avion voilà one shot alors
vous êtes pas tellement en colère quand
on lit votre bouquin vous avez pas
l'esprit tellement vengeur est-ce que
c'est le syndrome de Stockholm on leur
sait gré de nous avoir relativement bien
traité si on essaie de replacer tout ça
dans un contexte aussi on pourrait
aujourd'hui jouer les les victimes qui
ont été c'est pas le vrai on raconte la
vérité il nous dit pour vous ce sont des
terroristes ou des résistants lorsqu'ils
détiennent des journalistes étrangères
ou les civils ce sont issus de méthodes
terroristes mais quand ils se battent
contre les Américains c'est des
résistants pour vous avez une phrase
dans le bouquin vous dites il faut bien
admettre qu'un résistant islamiste et
c'est aussi un résistant
le Hezbollah libanais quand il était
quand la présence israélienne au Sud
Liban tout le monde considérait que
c'était des résistants ils étaient
barbus Lionel Jospin qui a considéré que
c'est les terroristes et ça lui a pas
apporté chance voilà je dis on peut pas
distinguer un résistant bon ou mauvais
en fonction d'une de sa barbe ou pas il
faut être logique avec soi-même donc on
essaie de recadrer de replacer tout ça
dans un contexte
voilà qui est encore en détention de
dire euh pas les insulter il y a quand
même une certaine responsabilité on peut
pas tout dire enfin dire n'importe quoi
s'il revient à couper en morceaux à
cause du bouquin ça a été d'ailleurs la
seule consigne voilà déjà donc même
l'enlèvement de Florence on dit
n'insultez pas vos ravisseur pensez au
prochain et là s'ils sont pas trompés
alors il y a un truc bizarre dans votre
bouquin c'est que dans la boîte à gants
de la voiture dans laquelle vous avez
été enlevé il y a la photo du fils de
votre chauffeur avec un général
américain le général km qui est quand
même le numéro 2 des forces américaines
en Irak et le fils du chauffeur
travaille peut-être pour les Américains
en tous les cas c'est une hypothèse
effectivement a dû travailler quelques
jours avec des Américains pour gagner 3
francs suisses et mais alors le
la folie de cette histoire c'est ce
qu'on lui a dit à boiman le jour même on
dit mais ton fils et toi vous détestez
les Américains et ton fils met dans ta
voiture une photo qui peut te couper la
tête alors lui à ce moment là il vous
dit c'est pas une photo normale
mais vous voyez bien que c'est pas un
mental vous êtes suffisamment en tout
cas ce qu'il faut dire c'est que c'était
vrai je veux dire le fils de notre
chauffeur et notre chauffeur ne sont pas
pour américains etc simplement le gosse
à 18 ans et on l'a voulu frimer devant
ses copains et un jour il est resté
ramener les revenus avec la photo avec
le général Kimmy au dessus de lui bras
dessus bras dessous etc et il en a
laissé quelques exemplaires dans la
voiture mais le soir même il voulait
couper la tête d'aboyer man ce qui était
tragique alors nous on a effectivement
dû convaincre et on y est parvenu enfin
ils ont été convaincus eux-mêmes que
tout ça était un montage et que et qui
n'était pas du tout un collaborateur des
Américains au moment où
on trouve cette photo du fils du
chauffeur avec le général américain dans
la boîte à gants vous pensez pas un
moment que tout ça était monté par les
Américains pour finalement montrer aux
Français que même des Français peuvent
être enlevés maltraités par les Irakiens
on sait pas que c'est le désinformation
non jamais pensé à ça non je pense
plutôt une une connerie de du fils de
notre chauffeur qui voilà parce qu'on
est vraiment sûr de notre chauffeur et
de son fils aussi il avait gagné une
bourse pour aller aux États-Unis trois
semaines avant j'avais essayé de le
convaincre d'y aller mais je veux pas y
aller j'aime pas les Américains je dis
mais tu ne sais pas tu as pas besoin
d'aimer bouche pour aller à l'univers
donc le premier jour on était se dit à
bohemian
c'est vraiment dans la dans la première
heure donc on est dans une petite cabane
les mains liées ils m'enlèvent il
m'enlève le bandeau il me met la photo
sous les yeux et moi j'avais pas mes
lunettes donc je vais pas bien et là
c'est là qu'il me donne deux claques le
flingue il me dit qu'il sait qui sait je
le reconnais pas et j'arrive à voir
et je reconnais bien sur le fils je le
connais pas je le connais pas pour
gagner du temps parce que et là c'était
un choc mais est-ce qu'on nous a suivi
depuis l'hôtel d'où vient cette photo
est-ce qu'ils ont été percussionniste
en une minute et là c'est quand même
flippant vous comptez retourner en Irak
attention et la prospérité
c'est pas demain il y a plus de
journalistes en fait on ira quand même
encore des journalistes encore des
journalistes les grandes agences
c'est pas du tout comme des journalistes
comme vous quoi il reste dans leur
bureau et ils font travailler des des
Irakiens et voilà c'est pas la
perfection loin de là mais ça permet
d'avoir une couverture tant bien que mal
mais tout à l'heure on disait que vous
pensiez beaucoup à Florence Aubenas moi
je pense qu'elle doit beaucoup penser à
vous surtout et puis elle doit se
raccrocher à se dénouement on espère
quand même
qui serait temps qu'il la libère parce
qu'elle est à 127 jours 128 même on
était libéré au bout de 124 bon on était
relativement bien traités mais au bout
de quatre mois quand même vous pensez à
ça commence à durer là vous rentrez dans
une longueur et là c'est une femme comme
ça c'est vraiment des hauts et des bas
quoi c'est repartent c'est vraiment et
puis on était deux donc on peut en
parler l'arabe donc on fait on pouvait
dialoguer une femme seule qui parle pas
l'air des trucs sur la longueur ou pas
voilà Christian chez nous Georges mal
Bruno mémoire d'otage c'est publié chez
Kalman les villes mesdames messieurs et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu